ps plus and xbox gold users have some
free games to play this october the
studio behind horizon forbidden west is
hiring for a multiplayer game and
netflix has entered the ring by
acquiring oxenfree developer night skull
studio i'm persia and this is your
gamespot news
the perks of having a ps plus or xbox
gold subscription includes free games
for you to play every month and october
has quite a bit to choose from for both
platforms sony has now officially
announced the free playstation plus
games for october 2021 and they include
one playstation 5 game hell let loose as
well as a pair of playstation 4 games
pga tour 2k21 and mortal kombat x hell
let loose is a world war ii multiplayer
game featuring 50 v50 matches that
combine shooting elements with an rts
inspired meta there are 14 soldier
classes to choose from and a variety of
weapons vehicles and equipment to use on
the battlefield and for all the fans of
our firearms expert series we've got an
awesome breakdown of hell let loose
weapons on our channel right now
on the xbox side of things microsoft has
announced the free games with gold
titles coming in october and there are
gonna be four in total these include
arrow
castlevania harmony of despair and
resident evil code veronica x well half
these games are from the 360 and the
other half are from the xbox one they'll
all be backwards compatible for the xbox
series x and s game pass users will also
be able to access these games when they
become available
horizon forbidden west developer gorilla
games new job listings appear to suggest
that a multiplayer game could be on the
way the company is looking to hire a
senior social systems designer who will
work in a core team of multiple
designers focusing on social systems and
player engagements and ideate create and
share innovative features to build
engage and nurture player interactions
and relationships the listing goes on to
say that the designer will create an
environment where compatible players can
create guild-like groups to explore
together
another job ad senior narrative system
designer points to a multiplayer game
being in the works as well it asks for
the applicant to have experience in
narrative design in open world rpg games
both single player and online co-op
elements were originally planned for the
first horizon game before getting
scrapped so it's possible the studio
might reintroduce a multiplayer element
for some future horizon games however
these listings aren't likely related to
the upcoming horizon forbidden west
since no news about a co-op element has
been mentioned yet in all of the
released pr content in teasers
netflix announced it has acquired night
school studio the developer behind
oxenfree after party and nextup nowhere
the developer is the first game studio
bought by netflix which earlier this
year announced its plans to expand into
the video game industry
sean crankle the night school studios
co-founder and director said in a
statement that netflix has a track
record for supporting diverse
storytellers which felt like a natural
fit for night school studio the netflix
team has shown the utmost care for
protecting our studio culture and
creative vision we'll keep making oxen
free too we'll keep cooking up new game
worlds mike verdu netflix's vice
president for game development made his
own statement on the acquisition saying
we'll continue working with developers
around the world and hiring the best
talent in the industry to deliver a
great collection of exclusive games
designed for every kind of gamer and any
level of play similar to netflix's shows
and films games will also be included in
the services memberships with the added
benefit of having no advertisements or
in-app purchases the first thing i think
about when i put netflix and games
together are all of the shows or movies
that i want a game version of let me
know in the comments which netflix
series you want to see converted into a
game and why is it squid game
new world has been full of surprises
since its boom in popularity as it's now
number one on steam but when it comes to
lakes or oceans you might not be able to
swim however you can definitely take a
stroll
if you enjoyed today's episode leave us
a like and subscribe so you don't miss
your next gamespot news update thank you
so much for tuning in and we'll catch
you next time
[Music]
baby
[Music]